meine damen und herren wir haben
ausführlich getagt das konnten sie
verfolgen und wir sind auch zu einem
guten ende gekommen unter den
schwierigen bedingungen
ich kann also über eine intensive und
konstruktive zusammenarbeit zwischen
bund und ländern berichten nicht nur
heute nachmittag sondern auch bei den
letzten tagen der vorbereitung möchte
ich auch ganz herzlich bei den ländern
bedanken die einen großen teil ja auch
dazu beigetragen haben
wir nähern uns dem ende des monats
november und wir hatten ja am 28 oktober
in dieser runde einschneidende und
befristete maßnahmen beschlossen
und heute haben wir wie vereinbart
unsere schlussfolgerungen aus dem
november gezogen und uns auf einen weg
durch die kommenden und für die
kommenden wochen geeinigt sie wissen
dass wir dies für einen längeren
zeitraum und nicht nur für zwei oder
drei wochen machen wollten
wir sind uns in unserer einschätzung wie
die mars haben sich ausgewirkt haben
einig der exponentielle anstieg der
infizierten zahlen ist gebrochen aus der
steil ansteigenden kurve sein flacher
verlaufen flach verlauf geworden
aber das ist nur ein teilerfolg er hat
uns hunderttausende von infektionen
erspart damit auch eine überlastung
unseres gesundheitssystems und viele
todesfälle
aber wir können uns mit diesem
teilerfolg auf gar keinen fall begnügen
die täglichen infektionszahlen verhauen
noch auf einem viel zu hohen plateau in
den intensivstationen wird zurzeit
enormes geleistet von meiner seite aus
ein herzliches dankeschön an ärzte und
pfleger und pflegerinnen viele kommen
bereits an ihre grenzen und die
nachricht des robert koch instituts das
in den letzten 24 stunden 410 menschen
an profit 19 gestorben sind erinnert uns
auf traurigste weise daran dass hinter
den statistiken eben menschliche
schicksale stehen lebenswege die zum
teil auch viel zu früh enden und das
lässt familien tief trauern um ihre
liebsten und deshalb ist es ein tag an
dem wir heute für die bürgerinnen und
bürger zwei botschaften haben einmal
danke
danke dass auch in den letzten wochen
und mund in den letzten wochen die
menschen in ihrer großen mehrheit die
gravierenden einschränkungen erneut
solidarisch mitgetragen haben und das
andere ist die klare aussage von bund
und ländern dass die lage es uns nicht
erlaubt die november maßnahmen
aufzuheben
wir sind noch viel zu weit von dem
zielwert von 50 als incidents pro 100000
einwohner in sieben tagen entfernt
ich bin weiter überzeugt und auch darin
waren wir uns heute einig wir müssen
dieses ziel weiter verfolgen
es ist nicht der einzige wert an dem wir
messen wo wir stehen in der pandemie
aber es ist der wert der darüber
entscheidet ob unser öffentlicher
gesundheitsdienst den infektionen
vollständig nachverfolgen und
infektionsketten unterbrechen kann oder
ob er dazu schlichtweg nicht mehr in der
lage ist wie es zurzeit in den
allermeisten landkreisen leider der fall
ist wir waren uns ja bewusst dass die
menschen von uns heute klarheit rollen
für den rest dieses jahres
das ist ihr recht und wir haben genau in
diesem sinne diskutiert es ist ein
besonderer monat der vor uns liegt der
dezember ein monat mit weihnachten und
dem jahreswechsel ganz besonders
wichtige tage gerade auch für die
christen aber auch für familien
insgesamt und wir haben das in unseren
beschlüssen berücksichtigt es kommt
jetzt weiterhin auf jeden und jede
einzelne an ansteckungen geschehen
überall dort wo menschen einander zu eng
oder zu unvorsichtig begegnen und wir
alle sind daher dringend aufgefordert
alle vermeidbaren also sind alle nicht
zwingenden kontakte zu vermeiden nicht
zwingend notwendige reisen nicht
anzutreten und auch in begegnungen nicht
stattfinden zu lassen und möglichst zu
hause zu bleiben
ich werde ihnen gleich einzelheiten der
beschlüsse erläutern möchte aber noch
einmal zusammengefasst sagen wir
brauchen noch einmal eine
kraftanstrengung geduld solidarität
disziplin werden noch einmal auf eine
harte probe gestellt
vieles deutet darauf hin dass
2021 uns erleichterung bringt und dieser
hoffnungsvollen gedanke gerade im blick
auf die impfstoffe ist vielleicht etwas
was uns hilft schritt für schritt dann
die pandemie zu überwinden und bis dahin
noch die geduld die solidarität
aufzubringen wenn ich die beschlüsse im
einzelnen kurz skizzieren dann heißt es
also weiter jeden nicht notwendigen
kontakt vermeiden
wir wollen und die arbeitgeber bitten
jede alle möglichkeiten für home office
zu nutzen insbesondere auch zu
ermöglichen zwischen den feiertagen
gegebenenfalls betriebsferien zu machen
oder menschen zu hause arbeiten zu
lassen
die bundesregierung wird gebeten gerade
was reisen ins europäische ausland
anbelangt in skigebiete zum beispiel zu
versuchen mit europäischen nachbarn zu
koordinieren ich sage ganz offen das
wird wahrscheinlich nicht einfach aber
wir werden zu versuchen die maßnahmen
vom 28 oktober werden also alle
fortgeführt erst einmal bis zum 20
dezember und wir gehen aber davon aus
dass sich bund und länder einig das
wegen des sehr hohen infektionsgeschehen
es die beschränkungen nach menschlichem
ermessen bis anfang januar gelten müssen
es sei denn wir haben einen unerwarteten
rückgang der infektionen unter 50 pro
100000 einwohner in sieben tagen
aber das ist leider im augenblick nicht
absehbar wir haben einige zusätzliche
maßnahmen ergriffen dass es müssen wir
tun damit wir aus dem plateau der
infektionszahlen herunterkommen
wir werden bei kleineren einkaufsläden
das gilt heute schon eine 1
quadratmeterzahl von 10 für pro kunden
haben und bei einkaufsflächen über 800
quadratmeter 20 quadratmeter für jeden
einzulassen den kunden und ganz wichtig
ist dass bei einkaufszentren ihr die
jeweilige gesamtverkaufsfläche
anzusetzen ist abweichungen können
länder die eine kleine incidents haben
also weniger als 50 pro 100000 zu lassen
das sind im augenblick
kommen dafür zwei bundesländer infrage
schleswig holstein und mecklenburg
vorpommern
aber wir haben vor allen dingen auch
darüber gesprochen dass auch härtere
maßnahmen ins auge gefasst werden müssen
hier ist es so dass wir eigentlich ja
sowieso eine hotspot strategie haben
zwischen bund und ländern die haben wir
schon vielmals vereinbart die gilt ab 50
neuinfektionen pro 100000 einwohner da
sind sofort ein konsequentes
beschränkung konzept notwendig und bei
weiter steigenden infektionsgeschehen
müssen dann zusätzliche maßnahmen
unternommen werden
und wir haben uns heute zusätzlich dazu
dieses hot spot konzept gilt weiter bei
besonders extremen infektions lagen wo
es eine indiz von über 200 neue
infektionen pro 100000 einwohner und
woche gibt und das infektionsgeschehen
diffus ist damit beschäftigt das dann
noch einmal umfassende allgemeinen
maßnahmen noch einmal erweitert werden
sollten und kurz um kurzfristig eine
absenkung zu erreichen
ich will für die bundesrepublik sagen
das betrifft zurzeit wenn man das land
berlin malz einer einheit nimmt berlin
und 62 weitere kreise landkreise in
denen überlegt werden muss wie man
situationsangepasst zusätzlich zu denen
aus bundesweit gilt noch einmal
gegebenenfalls weitere maßnahmen
einleiten muss die werden regional
sicherlich variieren
wir haben auch landkreise mit über 300
incident und da wird man sicherlich dann
noch mal schärfer angehen müssen
es wird die mund- und nasenschutz
pflicht zum tragen von und nasenschutz
noch einmal sehr stark intensiviert alle
orte mit publikumsverkehr den
innenstädten betriebs und arbeitsstätten
es wird hochschulen und unis auf
digitale lehre umgestellt mit bestimmten
ausnahmen im laborbetrieb und ähnlichem
und wir reduzieren noch einmal die
kontakte auf fünf menschen mit aus mit
zwei haus ständen wobei die kinder unter
14 ausgenommen werden
dazu gezählt werden können das ist
gegenüber der vorwoche noch einmal eine
verschärfung damit wir dann zu den
weihnachtstagen vom 23 12 bis längstens
erster januar ein fest im engsten
familien und freundeskreis mit maximal
zehn personen feiern können kinder die
dazu gehören unter 14 zählen auch hier
nicht es wird das gespräch mit den
religionsgemeinschaften gesucht damit es
keine großveranstaltung gibt im
zusammenhang mit feierlichkeiten zum
weihnachtsfest und wir haben sehr lange
darüber gesprochen dass wir uns ja einig
sind die schulen offen zu halten
aber wir haben an dieser stelle gesagt
was machen wir wenn es dann doch wieder
in bereichen sehr hoher instanz ist und
hier sind einige erweiternde maßnahmen
hinzugekommen auf der einen seite die
pflicht dann auch in den höheren
jahrgängen zum tragen eines mund
nasenschutz es auch in allen bereichen
der schule und es sollen dann bei
instanzen von über 200 dass es also
wieder ein teil dieser extremen
infektions lagen sollen weitergehende
maßnahmen für die unterrichtsgestaltung
in den älteren jahrgängen ab
jahrgangsstufe acht shows spezifisch
umgesetzt werden welche die umsetzung
der asl regeln besser gewährleisten
beispielsweise hybrid und wechsel
unterricht das heißt also aha da gibt es
im wesentlichen auch um die
abstandsregelungen wir haben uns
natürlich mit dem finanziellen ausgleich
befasst der analog zum november dann
auch wieder geleistet werden soll zum
dezember und zusätzlich gibt es dann bis
juni 2021 auch die überbrückungshilfe 3
und ein wichtiger gedanke waren noch auf
denen ich eingehen möchte die bullen
gruppen neben den sp zwei masken die wir
zur verfügung stellen wollen haben wir
noch einmal sehr stark daran gedacht
dass menschen in seniorenheimen
anderen einrichtungen ja auch ein gutes
weihnachtsfest haben müssen das darf
kein weihnachtsfest in einsamkeit sein
und deshalb werden wir hier ganz
besonders auf besuchsmöglichkeiten auch
achten
insgesamt war es eine sehr intensive
diskussion wo ich jetzt auch nicht auf
alle einzelheiten eingehen konnte die
klarheit schafft für die vor uns
liegende zeit die zeigt dass das eine
schwierige zeit sein wird in der wir
weiter daran arbeiten müssen die
fallzahlen pro tag herunter zu bekommen
und das heißt von takte weiter
reduzieren deshalb mussten wir an
einigen stellen noch einmal verschärfen
und das ist uns glaube ich gut gelungen
in der kombination mit möglichkeiten für
weihnachten und den jahreswechsel
herzlich
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren